hey man it's me kevin smith back in 1997
we opened up jay and silent bob's secret
stash my comic book store in red bank
new jersey
first it was on mama street for about
two years then we moved up to broad
street where it's been
at 35 broad street for the last 20 plus
years
but i'm here to tell you today ladies
and gentlemen that as of
december 28th jay and salam bob secret
stash
35 broad street will be closing her
doors
forever only to reopen at
65 broad street one block down still in
red bank new jersey yeah we're
building a new big stack ernie o'donnell
is building it
as we speak and man i've seen the video
it looks amazing so
we're going to a bigger space kids right
down the block but that means we are
leaving the stash we've been at for two
decades including
the stash where we shot comic book men
so
for all those who are like man comic
book men was my jam
which is like my mom and three people on
the internet you get to come
see the secret stash one last time all
of december
is set up for the last gasp of the
secret stash ladies and gentlemen so
folks can come through the door see the
old girl one last time before we close
the doors after the holidays and then
in the first or second week of january
we're gonna open
have a grand opening for jay and sam
bob's secret stash the new version
where we take the buddy christ and we
parade him from the old stash
to the new stash just like the montreal
canadiens did when they left their one
home rank and they they left the forum i
think it was and then they went to the
new rink and stuff
and they carried a torch we're going to
carry the buddy christ a procession
down to the brand new secret stash that
everybody could be involved in
of course you're going to have to wear
masks and hopefully they're going to
allow us out at this point but
there it is folks man jay and xylem bob
secret stash
uh the old version closing her doors
right after the holidays jay and salam
bob's secret stash the neo-stash
opening in the first or second week of
january right down the street at 65
broad street man for more information uh
go to smodcast.com
or jansalembob.com to learn
all about your last chance to see the
stash before the doors close
for good thank you for all your years
of uh patronage at the secret stash and
uh i beg you for more years of patronage
as we get ready to open the neo stash
that ernie's building
right now i'll see in red bank for the
last gasp of the secret stash